The shotlist is not about the
physical reality initially,
and not about the
physical reality
of where you're going to
shoot about what the sets are,
about what the
location is and stuff.
The shotlist is your
reminder of what's
important in the story.
Hey, everybody.
Oh my god, and what are
Dan Sasaki and George
Joblove doing in here?
I mean, it's like--
I get uncomfortable
speaking to people
who are smarter than I am.
But in any event, here we go.
Thank you so much,
and I'm really
happy to be here and doing
this for the Academy,
and happy to meet all of you.
What I do want to
talk about, though,
is where does style come from.
Because it really
comes from inside you.
You have within you
what you need in order
to create your own
personal style,
and we're going to
talk a little bit
and show you demonstrations
about how you can bring that
out of yourself so
that you can become
a creative person that actually
functions in this industry.
But let me tell you
this first of all--
I will bring up,
periodically, 11 observations.
I don't really have rules, but
I do have observations of things
that I feel are important
to keep in mind as you
go through this industry.
Observation number
one, the main thing
is to keep the main
thing the main thing.
What do I mean by that?
What I mean is this.
When you get into the
chaos of production,
it's very easy to
forget the point
of why you're doing something.
It's very easy to
just get blinded
by all the questions
and all the chaos
and everything that's
going on around you.
And then you forget to
get a critical shot that
tells a piece of the story, or
you forget to get a reaction,
or you forget that,
oh, I didn't set up
that light for the
main actress who
likes to be lit from the
side or whatever it is.
So when I get a script, I
immediately start shotlisting.
And what I mean "immediately,"
I don't give it the once over
and read the whole
thing, just scan it,
and then go back to
the beginning and start
shotlisting.
I start shotlisting as soon as
I open it, page one, scene one.
I read the scene, and then
I start shotlisting it
because in the process of
starting to shotlist it,
I'm reminding myself what the
story is and I'm telling myself
this is important.
When the man walks into the
room and he sees, in the corner,
something tucked
away, OK, well I
know I need to be able to
see him come in the room,
searching.
I need a shot of
whatever the object is.
It becomes the story.
And I've had so many
directors-- because I've
shot as a cinematographer
for hundreds of directors--
and I've listened to every
single excuse about why
they can't make a shotlist.
And honestly, I don't buy it
because the shotlist is not
about the physical
reality initially,
and not about the
physical reality
of where you're going to
shoot about what the sets are,
about what the
location is and stuff.
The shotlist is your
reminder of what's
important in the
story, the things
you need to remember when you're
on set that you need to tell.
That's what the shotlist is.
So I start shotlisting
right away.
And people are always amazed
when I do direct television
episodes, that on my
first day of prep,
when I walk into the
studio in the morning,
I have a complete shotlist
of the entire episode
if I got the script
the night before.
It only takes four to six
hours to do a shotlist
for a one-hour
episode of television.
And so how much
information do you
need in your initial shotlist?
Let me show you one of mine.
This is from an episode that
I directed of Pretty Little
Liars.
And I will tell you this--
I know a lot of you are
from different disciplines.
There are some
cinematographers, some people
want to be directors,
some production designers,
a whole bunch of things.
What I'm going to tell
you kind of encompasses
what everybody does
in this industry,
so I think it will
hopefully all be valuable.
So this is a script,
a page of a script
from an episode I directed
of Pretty Little Liars.
And let's concentrate on Scenes
31 and 32, Spencer's barns.
Fairly simple scene, which is
why I'm using it as an example.
"Spencer looks around the
ominously empty living room."
OK, so when I read a script, I
immediately key on to things,
descriptions like that.
"Ominously empty."
OK, that means something.
That suggests maybe a
certain visual treatment.
"She hurries to the bedroom.
She sees all of
Caleb's stuff is gone.
His side of the closet is empty.
His drawers too.
Her eye's drawn to the bed.
Propped against the pillows is
a framed picture of Goya's Dog.
Caleb left it there for her.
Spencer tenderly
picks up the picture,
sits on the edge of
the bed, staring at it.
She feels everything and
nothing at the same time."
OK.
So when I read that, this
very simple two scenes
suggested things to me.
It suggested to me that
there's an emptiness in her.
There's a framed
picture of Goya's Dog.
What does it mean?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
But I know that it's important
because they've singled it out.
So somewhere, in the
course of this show,
that image became important.
So I need to make
sure that I see it.
And what I'm looking for
are those kinds of details,
those kinds of insights into
the psychological makeup
of the character and how
the character's feeling,
and then how do I translate that
into a shot that will tell that
a part of the story.
So here we see Scenes 31 and 32.
I wrote in off angle,
full shot of Spencer
entering the house, a
wide shot of Spencer
with the empty house
in the foreground
so that she'd be small.
I had the blackness of
the closet revealing
Spencer, the door opening,
the close of the postcard
on the bed, and then a high
angle, a wide shot of Spencer
on the bed.
Those were the
setups that I felt
were going to convey the emotion
that character was feeling
in the script at
that moment in time.
And let me show you the
scene as it was in the show.
Caleb?
Now right about now,
you should be thinking,
oh my god, that's
alarmingly simple.
Yes.
Yes, it's alarmingly simple.
It's a reflection of your
impulse of how you felt
the story needed to be told.
And that is the essence
of where style comes from.
That is the essence of how you
develop your personal style is
how you interpret the
character seeing the world
or feeling the world
as they go through it.
And what happens then?
You make your initial shotlist.
I give my short list
immediately to the first AD
because it helps them schedule.
They're like, oh my god, so
in this quarter page scene,
you're thinking you may
have as many as 12 setups.
So they allow enough
time when they're
making their initial schedule.
The cinematographer
looks at it and says,
OK, if you want to do a shot
that goes under the table,
we may need a rig
and stuff like that.
And they can start putting it
on their special equipment list
if they don't carry it.
The production designer
says, oh, OK, you're
going to shoot from
inside the closet.
Means we may have to take
off the back of the closet.
I have to check the set
and see if that's possible,
and stuff like that.
So the wheels start
turning initially.
Now, once you do your scouts
and everything like that,
you're going to adapt and
change your shotlist according
to the realities, the physical
realities, the logistics
of what you're dealing with.
And that's where,
if you saw the--
here, I'll bring it up again.
On my shotlist, I have
indecipherable hieroglyphics
on one side.
There are little drawings that
only I really can understand,
but they become helpful
reminders for me.
If you see all those
scratches on the right,
sometimes it's overhead
diagrams with camera placements
in relation to actors,
and sometimes it's
actual frames to
remind myself of kind
of, compositionally,
what I was thinking of.
But they're little
pencil sketches.
I would never venture
to call them storyboards
because they're not.
But they're little
reminders for me
based on the actual
physicality of what I've seen.
Look at this.
This is a piece of a script
from a movie that I shot
called The Town That
Dreaded Sundown.
If you look at the bottom
right, where it says "On screen,
a scene from the
grainy, jumpy movie.
Audience screams, cheers.
Are watching The Town
That Dreaded Sundown.
There's a drunk old
man, Charles Pierce Jr."
And then the next page, we
have two teenage boys, Roy
and Johnny, walk to
the concession stand.
We settle on Corey and Jami.
They have a conversation.
It's their first date.
There is a reverend
hawking things,
and a bunch of church ladies.
And reverend is
saying real people
died as Corey and Jami leave.
OK, so that's the scene.
So when Alfonso and I were
talking about this movie
and we were walking through
all the beats, the story
beats, that had to be conveyed
at the beginning of this movie,
it was essentially an
introduction to characters.
So we need to introduce
people, but we
have no idea what the impact
of these people are yet.
We have no idea
who affects what.
Maybe the killer is in there.
We don't know.
But we needed to
establish this and provide
an atmosphere for the movie.
And ultimately, what
we decided to do
was what I'm going to
show you right now.
[SCREAMS]
Here we are, going over
the top of the screen.
So you're seeing the image
from the back of the screen.
And then we establish
the drive-in.
And we start honing in on
Corey and Jami, who are our two
principles, our two leads.
You're not enjoying
this, are you?
Oh, I just don't like these
kinds of films so much.
Why didn't you say so?
We can go.
Really?
Do you mean it?
[SCREAMING]
OK, so they get into their car.
Pulls us back, and
then we establish,
here's our two teenage boys.
Man, last time I saw this
movie was when I was like, 12.
You see that this is actually
a makeshift drive-in.
God bless you--
We see Charles Pierce,
Jr. sitting at this bar.
Creepily, we have no
idea who he is yet.
We start to hear the
reverend's voice.
Take a look at this, now.
This is a godless field.
We see the church
ladies putting flyers
through that people are ignoring
because they're too busy
making out.
Come to church on Sunday.
I'll tell you all about it.
We see the priest, and
we see the other church
ladies go back.
This is KYGL, Oldies
on the Border.
It's Halloween
night, so if you're
sitting at home waiting for the
trick or treaters to come by,
we'll keep you company
with our usual bang--
Real people died,
you know, young man?
Real people died.
That's right.
It's a godless field.
I'll see you on Sunday.
You're welcome.
That's good.
You leave.
This is a godless field.
It's good that you're leaving.
All right.
Simple, right?
That was actually the simplest
way to convey the information,
and it gave us a
sense of the town.
It gave us a sense of the
young people in the town.
It introduced,
sketchily, the people
who would be involved
in this movie.
And it also gave us
a sense of fluidity,
because In this movie,
we wanted the camera
to be able to infiltrate
people's lives.
This gets to my
point of simplicity
and why it's important.
KISS.
Normally, that means
"Keep It Short, Stupid."
In this case, it means
"Keep It Simple, Stupid."
OK, when people are in the quest
of trying to find their style,
they overcomplicate things.
They start thinking
in very grandiose,
difficult to
accomplish ways of how
to tell the story because
they want to make something
their visual signature.
I'm always looking for
what is the simplest
way to convey the information.
Well, let me show
you something that's
really kind of changed my life.
And this is a scene from a
movie that you've probably
seen, called The Graduate.
--way downstairs.
The Carlsons are here.
They are?
Well, come on.
They came all the
way from Tarzana.
Come on, let's get cracking.
It's a wonderful thing to
have so many devoted friends.
Hey, there's the
award-winning scholar!
We're all very
proud of you, Ben.
Thank you, Mrs. Carlson.
Is it the new car out there?
That little red Wop job?
That's Ben's graduation present.
Oh, you won't have much trouble
picking them up in that,
will you?
Sir?
The girls!
The chicks, the teeny boppers.
Oh, I think Ben's gotten
beyond the teeny bopper stage,
haven't you, Ben?
Yes, ma'am.
Excuse me, I think I'd just
like to check something
on the car for a minute.
His father bought
him an Alfa Romeo.
Hey, here's the track star.
How are you, track star?
Just fine, Mr. Loomis.
You get the point.
OK, so in the script--
you get the script.
It reads that there's a
huge party in his honor,
that everybody's there
drinking and eating
hors d'eouvres and happy.
And Benjamin is led
around the room and talks
to a whole bunch of different
people and stuff like that.
But what did you notice
about The Graduate?
Everything in that
scene, first of all,
is one shot that
was going around.
The camera was on this
uncomfortably tight close
up of Dustin Hoffman.
Everybody else was, like,
half of faces, people
that were sort of indistinct.
You didn't really get a
sense of who they were.
What were they doing?
They were trying to
make the audience feel
like Dustin Hoffman
felt. They were
trying to make the audience
feel that disorientation,
that disinterest, that
disconnectedness with what's
going on around him.
They wanted to make
the audience feel
as uncomfortable as
his character felt.
And if you look at The
Graduate, every single scene
in The Graduate does that.
Every single scene is
designed to make you feel
the way his character feels.
That is where your
style comes from.
I did the exact same
thing-- and this is a thing
that I do every single time.
I get the script,
I read it, and then
I climb into the head
of the characters.
Who's the main character?
And then I find some way to
visually depict the world
as the character feels it.
That becomes the style of
what it is that you do.
You're roping in the
audience into making
them be one with the character.
And the difference with
American Horror Story,
and the reason why my
cinematography in American
Horror Story got
so much attention,
is that every single
character in that show
was completely fucked up.
Completely dysfunctional,
couldn't deal with reality.
I was climbing into the
heads of crazy people,
and then visually
depicting the world the way
crazy people see it.
OK?
And that's why this show and
its visual style got attention.
Observation three, never
go with your first idea.
Never ever, ever go
with your first idea.
Why?
It may be a
fantastic first idea.
I will tell you this-- your
first idea for doing anything
is probably the most
conventional way
to do something.
You probably did it
before, if you have
any experience in the business.
You did it before, and you
probably did it successfully,
which is why you
want to do it again,
because everybody
wants to do what
they know everybody will love.
If you do that, you end up
endlessly repeating yourself.
You start doing the same shots
over and over and over again
because you know
people will like it.
And then you don't grow
as a creative artist.
You become stagnated.
And then ultimately, you become
that horrible four letter
word--
"hack."
You've become somebody who
just regurgitates and recycles
the same thing over
and over again.
And if you want to make
your mark in this industry
and you want to
survive, you have
to be somebody who is open
to reinventing yourself
constantly.
You say, well, my struggle
is to not compromise.
No.
Your struggle is
really to embrace
compromise because of this.
There's three types of shots
when you're figuring out
your coverage, how you're going
to shoot a scene as a director
or cinematographer.
And they're the shots that
are your personal artistic
flourish-- maybe these are
the things that you initially
thought of that you're
really excited about,
there are the shots that make
the basic storytelling more
exciting, and then
there are shots
that simply tell the story.
The type of shots that you
cannot get rid of ever are
the shots that tell the story.
If you don't get the
shots that tell the story
and make the story
understandable
and make the audience understand
why the character's feeling
the way they are, then you
have failed in your job
as a cinematographer or
director or anything.
You need to at least
get those shots.
I cannot tell you how many
times I've worked with directors
as a cinematographer and they
were going to walk away from
a scene without getting a shot
that actually tells the story
and makes that story
understandable.
Let me show you a
sample of a scene that
was a complete compromise.
You sound exactly like
my daughter Scarlett.
She's around your age, but she's
the oldest little girl I know.
I think deep down,
she blames herself
for everything
that's wrong with me.
But it's me.
Not her.
And it's him.
Not you.
I like you.
The simplest way, OK?
I had no time to do
what I wanted to,
which was I had this shot
that wrapped around them,
that rack focus between
him and her as the camera's
going around, and it
became this matrix,
this labyrinth of
the two of them
kind of intertwined
with each other.
Absolutely no time to do that.
All right, throw that out.
What is the second idea?
What do we do now?
And in that moment, I told the
operators, OK, this closeup,
just off frame.
Just give me half of
her face, you know?
And when we turn
around on Wes, we'll
just shoot the other
half of the face
and then I'll do cross
dissolves between them.
And Ryan Murphy, the creator
of the show, when he saw it--
originally, the scene
had much more dialogue.
She had more dialogue about
the abuse she suffered
from her father, but they
became uncomfortable with having
her say those words
after we shot it.
So they removed a bunch
of the dialogue, which
is why there was a dissolve
where he wasn't saying anything
and she wasn't saying anything.
But they wanted
to keep that layer
of dissolves, which they did.
That became the compromise.
That became the method by which
I demonstrated to the audience
that these two people were
getting in sync about how
they felt about the same thing.
And it was really simple.
Just off-frame this
way, off-frame this way,
and I'll just put dissolves
between the two of them.
So that's the second idea.
If I'd gone with
the first idea, it
wouldn't have been
nearly as interesting.
Observation four--
that's a quote from me.
"I have created an entire career
of making enormous compromise
look like an intentional style."
Absolutely right.
They'll probably put
that on my tombstone.
Everything that I did in
my entire career, certainly
everything I did on
American Horror Story,
was never my first idea.
It was a compromise.
It was a compromise because of
lack of money, lack of time,
lack of equipment, losing
actors at a certain time.
Everything was a compromise.
When you compromise, you have
to compromise in bold ways.
I always say, there's not one
way to light or shoot a scene.
There's hundreds and
hundreds of ways,
but people get locked
in to doing it,
oh, this is such a great idea.
I need to do it like this.
And then they short-circuit
their brain from functioning
by their depression in not
being able to get that,
and so they try to save it and
they whittle it down and say,
well, OK, what if I
just do this, what if--
don't do that.
Throw it away.
You can't do it.
You can't accomplish it.
You don't have the time
or resources to do it.
Find a different idea.
So let me go into
inspiration a little bit.
Where does the
inspiration come from?
Well, it comes from
everywhere, honestly.
It comes from your
life, it comes
from works of art, from
photographs, from other movies,
from paintings.
But you have to be open to it.
And people say, well, you
know, I feel uninspired.
And here's a little
exercise for you.
Tomorrow, you probably get up
off the same side of the bed
every single day,
I would imagine.
Tomorrow, get up on a
different side of the bed
or climb to the end of
the bed and get out of bed
if you can't get
out from the side.
Just get out of bed
on a different side.
All of a sudden, you will feel
like your world has changed.
Just trying to shake up
your world a little bit
and expose yourself
to different things.
And let me show you something
in the vein of change
for, or using other
inspirations, for what you do.
This is an artist--
I'm going to show you a couple
of photos of an artist called
Gregory Crewdson.
When we were prepping to
shoot The Town That Dreaded
Sundown, that clip I showed
you in the drive-in theater,
Gregory Crewdson's work
became a cornerstone
of the visual
approach to the show.
Because you see this interior,
and it has an unreality.
It has almost an artificiality,
almost a Hollywood kind of feel
about it, even though
it's very noir-ish.
And his work, like this,
became part of the signature,
I think, of the feel of
the show because something
about his work appealed to
Alfonso Gomez-Rejon, who
was the director, and myself,
who's the cinematographer.
And so that feeling
was something
that we wanted to carry
through in the movie.
And I want to show
you a scene that
was a direct inspiration from,
actually, that last photograph
that I showed you.
Because normally,
the inspirations
don't end up being translated
so directly into the movie.
But this was one
instance where it
did because that
inspiration was so perfect.
Tomorrow for sure?
So that photograph became the
perfect image of the feeling
that I want to get between
these two characters
at this point in the movie.
But it took design.
You know, we put
him in a red jacket
specifically because
I was going to use
only that light as the only
source for the entire scene.
And I didn't want
her face to go blue.
So we put him in a red
jacket so the light
that bounced off of him onto her
would be a more natural color.
And then we put
her in a blue top
because I wanted to keep up the
mystery of him as to whether
or not he was the killer.
One thing, if I can impress
upon you, as cinematographers,
those of you who are
cinematographers, one thing--
every now and then, I
will work with somebody,
as I'm directing,
who will say, well,
we can't shoot that way
because the light has
to come from this way.
And I'll just say, why?
And they'll say, because
that's where the windows are
and that's where the light
would come from in reality.
And I really kind of feel like,
when did it become our job
to recreate reality?
Isn't our job to
create the reality that
works for the drama,
that works for how
we're trying to make
the audience feel
about the characters?
You have to have the conviction
that this is the way I
want to tell the story.
What is the best way
to tell the story?
How is the audience going
to emotionally plug-in
to what it is that I'm
trying to get them to do?
There is no such
thing as bad lighting.
No such thing as bad lighting.
I totally, totally,
honestly really stress this.
Let me ask you this--
if we're doing a scene,
if I'm the main character
and this is the way I'm lit,
and my line of dialogue is,
"Sweetheart, I love you,"
you could look at this
and say, wow, that's
really bad lighting.
But if my line of
dialogue is "I'm
going to rip your guts
out and kill you,"
all of a sudden, not only has
the lighting gotten better,
but it's making
the audience feel
the angst of that character, OK?
So when people say, well,
that's bad lighting,
normally what they're
reacting to is lighting
that feels somehow
inappropriate for what
it is they're watching.
OK, you've violated the world
because you haven't connected
the visual style, the visual
end of what you're trying to do,
with the emotional end of what
the character is experiencing.
There's a disconnect.
But if you're connected
to the character,
you can get away
with murder, OK?
And that's where the
style comes from.
That's when it becomes
fun to really play
with those kinds of things.
And let me show you a
clip from something.
And I'm going to keep my
mic open because I want
to talk over this as it goes.
This is a scene from
American Horror Story,
and it's an episode where
a third of the episode
was going to be 16-millimeter
documentary footage.
You need an angle.
A hook.
And boy, did I have a doozy.
I heard from very
reliable sources--
The concept of this,
all this footage,
was that Sarah Paulson's
character, Lana Winters,
was going back to
the asylum where
she was an inmate,
with a documentary crew
and doing an expose
of the conditions
that they lived there.
And what Ryan Murphy told
me before we shot this is he
wanted it to look like
the Geraldo Rivera
documentary on mental
asylums from the 1970s.
Give me a thumbs up
if you can hear me.
OK, great.
So I started researching on
the internet the Geraldo Rivera
documentary, and I could
not find a good copy of it
anywhere.
Everything that I found was
multiple generations away,
looked really pukey and awful.
I could not find a
clean copy anywhere.
And what I realized
is, wait a minute,
If I can't find a copy of this,
then probably what Ryan saw
was a putrid, disgusting looking
copy of this documentary.
But what I did was I
took 16-millimeter film,
I underexposed it 3 stops, and I
force processed that negative 3
stops, and then I took all of
that 16-millimeter footage,
and I had it transferred it to
3/4-inch pneumatic videotape,
which was an antiquated system
that nobody used anymore,
those industrial tapes.
And then I had them transferred
back from 3/4-inch to high
definition files.
Your job as
cinematographers, directors,
is to tap into
that emotional core
and find the image that
makes the audience feel
that way, without regard of
what people will tell you,
this is not proper lighting.
Observation six, all
leading concepts consist
of four elements.
I know the process
of lighting sometimes
is very difficult for
people to understand.
And this is very valuable
for those of you, especially
who are not cinematographers,
because what
I'm going to explain
to you, probably a lot
of cinematographers
haven't thought of
or have complicated
to the point where it
becomes a more complex theory.
But this is what it is.
There are only four elements
to lighting, really.
It's the angle of the light,
the color of the light,
the intensity of the light,
and the acuity of the light.
Is it hard or soft?
Those are the four things
that are manipulated in order
to create the mood,
the effects, just
the general feel of any scene.
It's not rocket science,
where what separates
the artist, who's successful
from the person who is not,
is the inspiration
and the ability
to transfer that
inspiration into terms
that the rest of the
crew can jump on,
that your gaff, or your key
grip, and everybody else
can plug into; the wardrobe
designer, the costume,
the production designer.
They have to be able to
key into the visual concept
that you are presenting.
Let me show you something.
What is not in vogue
very much lately,
and it's really disappointing
to me, is using hard light.
Let me show you just a
quick couple of photos.
So this is lit with soft light.
This is an actress
lit with soft light.
And she looks pleasant
enough, but there
are little circles under
her eyes, and you know,
it's not maybe as
vibrant as I would like.
This is the same
face with hard light.
You see her eye color has
gotten more pronounced.
Why is that?
Because her pupils
are shrinking,
and it exposes more of the
color of the rest of her eye.
You see the lips, the
lipstick on her lips,
is more pure red in this.
And look at what's happening
with the bags under her eyes,
is the lightning is
washing them out.
And there is no
change in her makeup.
It's just changing from a soft
light to a hard light source.
Hard light was
the glamour choice
for lighting actresses for
many, many years in Hollywood.
And it's fallen out of favor.
Not many people are
using it anymore,
and I always loved
lighting, especially women,
with hard light.
But today, actresses
start to freak out
if they see hard light
because they think it's harsh.
And you have to
explain to them, well,
this is the glamour lighting of
the 1920s, '30s, '40s, and '50s
in Hollywood.
This is what makes
you look amazing.
People always ask, why
did Henry Fonda's eyes in
Once Upon a Time in the West
looks so piercingly blue?
Did he wear contact lenses?
No.
They had a big hard light in
front of his face, beaming
into his face, and it shrunk
down the pupil so much
that his blue eyes just popped.
I'm just going to get into a
little bit about the difference
between film and digital.
This is film emulsion.
What you notice about
the film emulsion is
that the silver halite
crystals, no two
are exactly the same shape
or size or color or anything.
OK, when light strikes
silver halite crystals,
when light strikes
the emulsion of film,
they rearrange themselves into a
myriad of kind of permutations.
And there is an unlimited
number of combinations
that they can go into, OK?
So the amount of
information that
can be stored on a piece
of motion picture film
is unlimited.
Here's another view of it.
The digital sensor is finite.
It doesn't have an infinite
amount of permutations.
It has, like, this many
pixels in a sensor,
or however many it is.
And it has to resolve
what it is that it's
going to resolve for the image
within that number of pixels.
So what happens, then,
when you go into shooting?
Well, what happened initially
with the initial digital
cameras, this is a painting
by George Seurat called Sunday
in the Park.
And the actual
painting is hanging
in the Art Institute of
Chicago, and it's the size
of your apartment wall.
It's big.
It's really big.
But when you walk up
close to it, what you find
is that the brown of the
skin is not just brown.
It's got blue, it's got
yellow, it's got red in it.
The face also has
different pigments.
The dog, the brown
dog, is not just brown.
And this is what you're looking
at when you stand back from it.
Especially early digital
cameras could not resolve color.
It didn't have the color depth
to do that kind of thing.
So what it did was it emphasized
the colors that it could.
So you had green grass
that was very, very
green, that didn't have other
gradations of color in it.
You had blue water.
And people said, well, wow, this
digital camera, this high def
camera is way too sharp.
Well, no.
The problem was that the initial
high def cameras were not
sharp enough.
They could not store
enough data to give us
a more rounded, accurate,
realistic picture of what
it is it was seeing, so
it emphasized the things
that it could see.
And that created a
perceived sharpness
that people misinterpreted
as being sharper than film.
Part of the reason
why I bring that up
is because you shouldn't get
obsessed with chasing Ks.
Everybody is like,
ah, well, this is 2K.
Yeah, but I've got 4K.
Yeah, but I can do this in 8K.
The Ks don't matter as much
for you during production.
I mean, they probably
matter a lot in post,
but you should be choosing
the medium that you shoot on
based on, aesthetically,
does it give you
what it is that you
want for that project?
Does it convey what it
is that you want to say?
Because our palette,
as filmmakers,
should be wide open to
use whatever they want to,
and not just limited to you
have to use this 8K camera.
Observation number seven.
Don't sit at video village.
Just don't.
And I don't care if
you're the director
or the cinematographer,
just don't do that.
It's really a pet peeve
for me that people--
we've grown up now,
we're growing up now
in this culture
of people who sit
at video village with a
cappuccino in their hands
and headphones on their
heads in a comfy chair,
and then, if they're
directors, they
scream direction over a wall
from another room at actors.
Directing is not
a passive sport.
It's a contact sport, OK?
You need to be on your feet,
those of you who are directors.
I don't believe the
director should ever
be sitting down and directing.
I don't believe that a
cinematographer should be
stuck in a black tent all day.
When you live inside
the tent, when
you live inside the
black tent with the DIT,
as a cinematographer,
you lose the connectivity
with the actors.
There's always been such
a great relationship
between cinematographers
and actors.
And that's starting to erode
because the cinematographer
spends all of their
time in the tent.
I think that's a mistake.
100% of my concentration
is on the performers.
100%, OK?
And I stand there six
feet away from them,
and I watch them
while they perform.
I can't tell you how
many television actors
have told me, oh my god, you're
always there by the camera.
Even if we can't see you because
you don't stand in our eyeline,
but we know you're
always there, and I
feel like my performance
has consequences.
I feel like my
performance is important
because I'm not being
yelled at from another room
or being told direction
or adjustments
from an AD, a second
AD, on a walkie-talkie.
That's important, OK?
That's how you get the
performance that you want.
And that's how you make
the set go very fast.
And then when I
direct the actors,
after I get a take that I love--
and it could be take number one.
With Gary Oldman, 40% of the
time, it was take number one.
After I get a performance
that I love, and I call cut,
I immediately ask the
crew, is everybody good?
And the operators,
the assistants,
and the dolly
pushers especially,
they know what I mean.
If anything went wrong in their
part of what we were doing,
all they need to do
is tell me right away,
"I need another one."
It's just a fast way to work,
and it's a great connectivity.
I also like to cut.
I love the word "cut."
Today, they're like, let it
roll, keep the camera rolling.
I'm just going to go in
there and adjust something.
Keep rolling.
So excuse me, why?
Why?
In post, if they have to
sift through 40 minutes
of a running camera to find
the 20 seconds that was good,
they are spending their time
researching and not editing.
You need to give
them less footage.
You need to give them
more good footage.
So "cut" is a valuable word
that seems to be disappearing
from the lexicon.
OK.
What are unsafe hours?
It's the hours that you
work that contribute
to fatigue of the crew.
What happens when you
work a significant number
of consecutive long-hour days,
14, 15, 16 hours every day?
Well, three things happen.
The creativity suffers,
the crew gets exhausted,
safety goes out the
window, and it's
expensive to pay for
all the overtime.
In a lot of cases,
the scripts are
written too large
to be accomplished
in the amount of time that
the studio or the network
wants them done in.
And the directors are
saying, oh, OK, well,
what's pull the plug time?
We pull the plug in 14 hours,
we pull the plug in 16 hours.
Oh, great.
I've got 16 hours to go.
No.
Wrong way to approach it.
In 25 episodes that I've
directed of television
in the last 3 and 1/2 years,
I have not had a single day
go over 12 hours.
Most of my days are 10
and 1/2 to 12 hours.
I won't say that I won't
work over 12 hours,
because there may be extenuating
circumstances where you
have to work that 13th hour.
But all the crews
that I work with
know that when that
12-hour mark comes,
I'll probably be in my van
going back to the airport
or to the hotel.
You have to portion
out your day.
And I want to see a show
of hands, how many of you
love interviewing for a job?
Honestly, raise your hands.
Coco, Jose, Carley,
and Gabriel, and Dan.
OK, and the rest of you, I take
it-- oh, Milan and Caterina.
Good, good.
Let me tell you this--
interviewing for a
job in this industry
is my favorite thing to do in
the world, truly and honestly.
If I could get paid to
just interview for jobs
and never have to
do the job, I would
be the happiest guy on Earth.
The job interview
is my time to play.
And the reason why
it's my time to play
is because it's the only
time that job is perfect.
It's the only time you're not
worried about budget schedules,
difficult actors, whatever.
It's the only time
that job is perfect.
So I love the job interview.
What are they trying
to figure out?
Those of you who don't
like job interviews,
what are they trying to figure
out when they interview you
for a job?
There's only two things,
and two things only.
They want to know if they like
you, and if they trust you.
That's it.
That's what they're trying
to learn in a job interview.
And when people go
into a job interview
and they're freaked
out, you know,
they come in, and
when the people say--
the first question is
always, always simple.
And it's usually, so, Alejandra,
what have you been up to?
And a lot of people will just
start reciting their resume.
Well, I shot this
movie, and I did this,
and I worked as an electrician
on this, and stuff--
no.
This is your opportunity to tell
them something about you that
speaks to your
passion as a person,
as a creative person
in this industry.
I went to one job
interview where they said,
so Michael, what
have you been up to?
And I said, I just built a
railroad train around my house.
And they're like, what?
I said, I just jackhammered all
this cement around my house,
I laid in steel rail,
I repoured the cement,
and I have railroad
trains, electric trains,
now that we can ride
around the house.
And they said, do you
have pictures of this?
And I said, yes, I do.
And I showed them
pictures of my trains.
And they said, what
motivated you to do that?
And I talked about how when
I was a kid, we had no money
and I always imagined
I had a train,
but I'd draw train tracks with
chalk around our apartment
building in Chicago.
And I told my wife, I
want to build a train.
And she's like, don't
you think the kids
are going to be
too old for trains
by the time you finish this?
I said, well, it's not
really for the kids.
It's for me.
And she says, OK.
Let's build your railroad then.
We talked for a half
hour about my train,
and we never talked
about the job.
And they hired me.
They are trying to find
out if they like you
and if they trust you, OK?
And the other thing people say
when they go into interviews,
they say, well, I'm afraid
I don't have the experience
that they're looking for.
Let me tell you this--
people will forgive
a lack of experience.
They will not forgive
a lack of confidence.
And I don't mean, like,
bullshit confidence
like bravado and stuff.
I'm talking about if
Madison goes in for a job
and Destiny goes in for the
same job, and Madison is like--
and they say, well, you need
to do this and this and this.
And she says,
well, I don't know.
I've never tried that.
I mean, I'll try.
I mean, I hope I
don't mess it up.
And Destiny goes in and
says, you know what?
Honestly, I've never done
that before, but I learn fast
and I work hard and I
will make it happen.
Which person do
you want to hire?
So you have to go into that job
interview with your conviction.
If you're the
cinematographer, you've
gotten the script probably.
You've gone through it.
You've made your notations.
Maybe you've brought
in visual samples,
which is great, on your
computer that you can show them.
This is how I see this.
I did one job interview--
and people are always
afraid, well, what if my
vision doesn't match theirs?
I tell you, I guarantee
you, nine times out of 10,
they don't have a vision yet.
They are looking at you to
come in and give them vision.
So you do that.
You do that unapologetically,
you do that completely,
concisely.
There was one job
interview, I went to
with a director who directs
$100 million movies.
It was for a pilot.
And I said, wow, I see
this program like 1970s
kung fu movies
stylistically, but bad,
low budget 1970s kung fu movies.
I see the camera, like, zooming
in erratically but having
to re-frame on the fly because
they didn't get the composition
right and they didn't
have enough money
to do a second take and stuff.
I think it has that
kind of nervous energy.
And he listened to me talk
for, like, five minutes,
and he said wow, I don't
see it like that at all.
But you really
thought about this,
so we should work
together and figure out
what the style actually is.
And we did.
I worked on that show.
You have to come in
with a vision, committed
to your vision, OK?
And when people are
in the job interview,
and especially when you
start getting up in level
and working on
larger productions,
there's not just one person
that you're interviewing with.
It's like a room
of seven people.
People start to get freaked out.
And they sit there, and they
answer the first question,
and then they read the room.
They look around,
like, who's nodding,
who's shaking their head,
who's scratching on their pad?
And then because you're trying
to calibrate what it is you're
going to say next,
because you want
to say what they want to hear,
big mistake for two reasons.
Number one, they
know you're lying.
They know that
you don't actually
believe the words that are
coming out of your mouth.
They know that you're trying
to say things that whatever are
you think they want to hear.
They know that.
You're not actors.
You can't put that over.
So you have to give that up.
Don't read the room.
And the second
thing that happens--
and this is the most damaging--
is that they become
convinced that you do not
have an original creative
idea of your own,
and then you're
dead in the room,
and the interview
is officially over.
It may go on for another
minute, out of courtesy,
but they're done with you
once they've decided that.
So don't do that.
Don't read the room.
Go in there with
your point of view,
go in there with your
vision, express it to them.
It's such an important
part of what you're
going to do when you
leave this program, when
you go leave school or
whatever and you go off
to do your things.
You need to get comfortable
with the job interview, OK?
And more and more
important, agents.
Everybody talks about agents,
or I need the perfect reel,
or whatever like that.
Tell you, that face to face
encounter is more important.
You need to cultivate all
of these relationships
with people.
And if you're the
kind of person who
doesn't like to call
people because you
think you're bugging them,
especially you need to do it.
So you need to get
contact information,
and people are very
afraid to do that.
You have to get over
that fear because it's
your responsibility.
If you don't do that,
you remain invisible.
And invisible is not what you
want to be in this business,
OK?
Let me just cover a couple
of other quick things,
and then we'll get
into to some questions.
99% of the people
in this business who
want to get into this business
will not produce anything,
will not do anything, will not
step out of their comfort zone.
And I'll tell you this--
it's not fear of failure
that stops people.
It is fear of success.
When you set yourself a goal,
and let's say you get there,
is that it?
Is at the end?
No.
It's the beginning,
because that opens up
to other possibilities.
So I have to choose between
this one and this one,
and you're like, uh, shit.
OK, I'll choose this one,
so you follow that path.
And let's say that that's
the right decision.
Is that it?
No.
Because that leads
to this, and you
have to make another
decision, which way do I go?
Success is an ongoing,
complete cycle
of constantly stepping
into the things
that you've never done before,
the experiences that you've
never had, the things that
you're not sure if you can do,
and going in and doing it.
OK?
And what did Yoda say?
Yoda said "Do, or do not.
There is no try."
Don't try to do something.
Do it.
Commit to it.
The last point I would
like to make, get a life.
You're creative people
and whatever you do,
whatever your field of what
you want to pursue in the film
business is, you can only
do that if you have a life
outside of the film business.
Because if you cut yourself
off from life experiences,
then what is going
to happen is you
will have no stories to tell.
You will have no experiences
to draw from for your art.
You need to have a life
outside of this business.
So does anybody have any
questions they'd like to ask?
Leeann Leonard, one of our
cinematography track students.
Hey, Leeann.
Hi.
I wanted to know, can you
manipulate the principal light
with mood as much as possible?
So there's an enormous
amount of manipulation
you can do with a
principal light source.
And like I said, I very rarely
use more than three lights.
Early on in my career, I
was using the whole truck
full of lights, and I found
that when they were shutting off
the lights after the
scene was finished,
the scene looked better.
So I said, OK, I'm going
to start with nothing.
If I walk in and
it looks great, I'm
just going to start
shooting, which
drives the ADs crazy, because
oh man, we figured you're going
to take a half hour to light.
No, I'm done.
Just waiting on you.
Hello, Sir.
Thank you.
Thank you for your
time, as well.
My question is which
is a better approach,
is it better to have
the camera movement
or dictate the blocking, or
just block the actors first
and then choose the camera
movements depending on them?
Sometimes, I have a
movement in my head
because I feel like
that movement expresses
something about the character.
But when I do the
blocking, sometimes
where the actor is going
or what we worked out
is not accommodating
to that movement.
So I just come up
with something else.
I love the actors who
challenge me as a director
and as a cinematographer,
but I love the ones
who question everything.
Sometimes they're the ones
that the ADs or the producers
don't like because they
question everything.
I love those people because
all those questions are never
coming from ego.
They're coming from their
passion and their commitment
to their character and
what they want to do.
And that helps me drive
forward, ultimately,
what that scene becomes.
Thank you so much, Michael.
Thank you.
I think we can all
unmute ourselves and tell
Michael how amazing he is.
That was so informative.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Thank you so much.
That was awesome.
Thank you so much, Michael.
You're the best, man.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Farewell.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--Michael.
Thank you.
Awesome.
I'm expecting amazing
things out of you.
I mean, you're in the
Academy Gold program.
I mean, this is not some
slouchy, second second-hand fly
by.
This is the Academy.
You need to step up and
do amazing things, OK?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.